bonsoir bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu sur
tv fil 78 pour ne rien manquer de
l'actualité locale le journal de la
rédaction voici les titres de ce 21 mai
après besoin d'activités de services en
santé de l'assurance maladie dresse le
bilan dix mille visiteurs ont franchi la
porte des espaces santé active nous en
parlons avec une marque de bach le
directeur général adjoint de la cpam
benoît hamon aurélie filippetti françois
hollande présents sur scène pour
désherber décerner les trophées
d'improvisation de déclic théâtre le
tournoi national de la compagnie tra
piste s'est achevée à paris le parrain
jamel debbouze y était également x men
sur les écrans depuis ce mercredi au
casting un autre rapist célèbre omar sy
images et interviews du comédien à
suivre
l'image du jour c'est ce rappeur plaisir
roi surnommé beretta 9 mm interpellés
tôt dans la matinée dans le quartier du
val hibou suspecté avec une douzaine
d'autres personnes également arrêté aux
clayes-sous-bois et à villepreux de
participer activement un trafic de
drogue cocaïne cannabis plusieurs
milliers d'euros et des voitures ont été
saisies dans son dernier clip dont vous
voyez les images voyoucratie beretta 9
mm faisait l'éloge de la violence et des
trafics en tous genres il aurait déjà
été condamné pour des faits similaires
par la justice l'invité de ce 21 mai
marque de bach bonsoir et bienvenue en
plateau au directeur général adjoint de
la ceppm 78 la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines voici
deux ans vous lanciez ce dispositif
santé active le bilan aujourd'hui plus
de dix mille visiteurs sur les antennes
dédiées à poissy ou encore à versailles
et puis aussi plus de 3000 adhérents au
dispositif de coaching on va juste
commencé par rappeler comment
fonctionnent ces sept ce dispositif
santé active que vous avez mis en place
le dispositif santé active fonctionne de
manière très ferme sur la base du
volontariat
chaque assuré à partir de l'âge de 18
ans est invitée à franchir les portes
des deux espaces existants à versailles
et
et à poissy et de venir nous rencontrer
pour nous exposer sa motivation à garder
ou préserver son capital santé
tout ça est entièrement gratuit financé
par la caisse primaire est notamment
l'un des pôles d'attraction c'est de
pouvoir bénéficier du bilan nutrition
avec une diététicienne bilan gratuit
pendant une heure à relever pour la cpmc
de développer le prévenir plutôt que
guérir
nous avons envie de nous adresser
aujourd'hui à une population qui est
encore en bonne santé et qui a envie de
préserver son capital santé et de
prendre de bonnes habitudes seront en
termes de nutrition en terme de
préservation de la santé du dos ou en
termes de santé du coeur est en effet de
vieillir le plus longtemps possible en
bonne santé
c'est l'objectif que l'on se donne
est-ce que c'est efficace est ce que
vous ressentez déjà les effets sur les
finances par exemple
alors pour l'instant il est un peu trop
tôt pour deux ans seulement
nous allons mener dans la deuxième
partie de l'année 2014 n'est pas une
première évaluation économique qui nous
montrera si nous sommes sur le bon
chemin
en tout cas les premiers retours
qualitatif de la part de nos de nos
assurés qu'ils sont très positives car
ils nous disent que ils ont retrouvé ou
pris connaissance de deux bons réflexes
à adopter pour la vie pour la vie future
justement c'est mon réflexe les avez
vous prenez-vous soin de votre santé
c'est notre question du jour micro
trottoir en faisant du sport en ayant
une alimentation équilibrée
en essayant de pas manger trop gras
aussi donc voilà c'est oui un mix entre
le sport et l'alimentation
on fait ce qu'on peut pareil on mange le
plus sain possible mais on ne sait pas
ce qu'on mange alors au moins gens
équilibrés en faisant du sport soit avec
eux c'est pas quelque chose auquel je
prends parti fin j'ai particulièrement
attention en fait après je mange pas des
choses trop trop horrible où j'essaye de
de faire des soins ou des choses comme
ça en pratiquant de l'exercice environ
une heure par jour de marché en mangeant
pas mal de fruits de légumes mais je
vais régulièrement mes examens analyses
de sang comme on appelle ça mammographie
les gens suivent plutôt les conseils et
font attention à ce qu'ils mangent ils
font du sport aussi c'est une attitude
qui n'existaient pas forcément
auparavant aujourd'hui à une prise de
conscience ou est tout à fait on voit
bien que franchissent la porte de nos
boutiques des assurés qui veulent
trouver les bons conseils et qui veulent
prolonger souvent en effet des bonnes
habitudes qu'ils ont déjà commencé à
apprendre notamment la pratique de
l'activité physique la nutrition la
filière nutrition et la filière qui
rencontrent le plus de succès est un
on va on a beaucoup de demandes pour que
pour ce parcours que les gens veulent
comprendre comment manger équilibré mais
avait aussi des questions très simples
que peut-on manger équilibré pas pour
pour pas très cher et donc les ateliers
les aide à progresser dans ce domaine
répondait aussi à ces questions le
programme santé actifs que vous
développez donc s'articule pour la
partie coaching vous l'avez dit autour
de la nutrition et de la santé du dos du
coeur également ses choix vous les avez
fait parce que vous avez identifié les
besoins spécifiques parler de la
nutrition on l'a bien compris mais sur
le dos aussi le coeur voilà on
s'aperçoit que dans le département des
yvelines par exemple sur la nutrition
part même si le rapport est pas
forcément évident mais on a plus 35000
diabétiques donc on se dit
qu'aujourd'hui
ne pas tomber dans le diabète ça peut
être important et puis on avait beaucoup
de remontées du terrain de la part de
salariés qui n'auront dit j'ai rencontré
des problèmes de dos beaucoup
d'employeurs figuier
nous avons beaucoup d'arrêts de travail
de salariés qui sont victimes de
lamballe j ou dorsales j ai donc
travailler sur les bonnes postures
apprendre à relaxer son dos à en prendre
soin ça fait partie du programme
l'espace santé active il y a deux
antennes actuellement département l'une
à poissy l'autre à versailles vous à
l'élargir sur d'autres communes à saint
valentin
voilà nous nous avons une ambition en
effet de d'ouvrir un troisième expert
nous avons un projet sur saint quentin
en yvelines nous sommes dans l'attenté
des autorisations nécessaires pour le
faire je pense qu'on aura une de la
visibilité au cours du deuxième semestre
de cette année pour autant tous les
bénéficiaires de saint-quentin peuvent
déjà soit venir aux espaces de
versailles 2 ou de poissy mais nous
faisons également des ateliers
délocaliser mais nous avons la chance
avec la commune la communauté
d'agglomération de saint-quentin d'avoir
un partenaire extrêmement efficace qui
relaie bien nos actions
l'antenne éventuelle sur 50 ans divine
sera installé au elle sera située à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici
samedi boulevard vauban puisque près
près du centre de sécurité sociale qui
existe déjà de guyancourt et de
montigny-le-bretonneux ce sera
l'occasion pour nous salariés voisin de
venir vous voir également avec le but
c'est de faire des économies ça on le
disait tout à l'heure les finances
justement la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie dans les yvelines se porte bien
se porte mieux
alors on parle souvent du trou de la
sécu des économies à faire c'est
l'occasion de vous poser la question
disons qu'aujourd'hui
le contexte financier reste reste un
contexte difficile il faut savoir que la
caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie
distribuer quasiment 4 milliards de
prestations d'euros dans l'année une
bonne partie de ses prestations vont
vers les prestations hospitalières et
donc en tout cas on est vraiment un
objectif fixé nationalement de maîtrise
des dépenses extrêmement ambitieux
puisque cette année le gouvernement ne
nous demandera probablement de faire 2 %
au moins de 2% d'évolution est donc
évidemment c'est dans ce secteur là
qu'on oriente tous nos efforts ça fait
combien financièrement parlant vous
parlez de pourcentage mais en termes
d'euros le déficit aujourd'hui de
combien il faut le réduire
alors aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
déficit locale par par département il ya
un déficit est un déficit national
l'année
l'année s'est terminée à un peu plus de
6 milliards pour la branche maladie
et donc voilà c'est l'effort et
l'effort est donc de cette ampleur là
évidemment il se fera pas sur uniquement
l'exercice 2014 mais de manière
prononcée sur les deux ou trois gènes
les deux ou trois années à venir
même si les dépenses en tout cas ne sont
pas faites par département il ya des
économies par département sur certains
secteurs à faire aujourd'hui vous devez
réduire on vous demande de réduire sur
certains secteurs
en tout cas on nous demande d'être très
vigilants sur certaines dépenses
les dépenses liées aux indemnités
journalières liées au carré de travail
donc c'est à dire l'arrêt de travail
donc je pris au bon à bon escient des
efforts également à réaliser en matière
de frais de transport par exemple et sur
les prescriptions de médicaments aussi
alors sur les présélections ont pointé
du doigt au niveau national en
prescrivent trop sur les prescriptions
de médicaments
nous sommes évidemment peut-être pas
encore suffisamment performants mais en
tout cas depuis deux ans la consommation
de médicaments a tendance à ralentir au
niveau national c'est incontestable et
même au niveau du département
on constate aujourd'hui une prise de
conscience et je pense aussi que les
grecs sont plus méfiants par à bord a
appris que deux médicaments et je pense
qu'on peut y voir un effet des
différentes affaires qui ont défrayé la
chronique
et puis ils prennent conscience aussi de
l'importance de la santé de se
renseigner au quotidien on en revient
donc au dispositif santé active que vous
avez lancé voici deux ans et le deuxième
anniversaire cette année et forcément
comme tout anniversaire ça se fête
il ya eu déjà sur l'antenne de
versailles des manifestations de
proposer là ce sera possible le 24 mai
va se dérouler comme en tout à fait
calmes dit après midi 200 la plage dont
georges pompidou ce devant l'expression
est active
notre animateur sportif jeremic sera là
tout l'après-midi pour animer des
ateliers d'activités physiques alors
divers et variés en fonction du public
nocera de la clim nastic douce de la
relaxation des choses un peu plus active
et puis nos animatrices santé actifs
seront également là pour accueillir la
population y aura dégustation de
cocktails de fruits de saison et puis
évidemment tous les nouveaux adhérents
seront les bienvenues et on leur
expliquera comment prendre soin de leur
santé
c'est l'occasion de découvrir ces
espaces santé active merci à vous je
rappelle qu'il fait leur à deux ans deux
ans de ce dispositif renseignements
complémentaires sur le site internet ma
santé active le site qui s'est affichée
merci encore on reste dans ce domaine de
la santé septième année consécutive à la
maison des parents de trappes pour cette
semaine
mangez bougez une semaine qui donne les
clés pour être en bonne santé financé
notamment par lee ps l'institut de
promotion de la santé par l' agence
régionale de santé
l'action sensibilise tous les publics
des enfants aux parents en passant par
les personnes âgées
eolen thorez elodie moines
d'importants apprendre aux enfants les
bons gestes du quotidien qu'elle peut
aussi le faire en chansons pour cette
6ème édition de la semaine mangerbouger
attrape la maison des parents et ses
partenaires proposent un nouveau
spectacle bien dans ses baskets
j'accueille les ventes et écoutez
maintenant l'action s'est déroulé sur
une semaine et a proposé différentes
activités avec le même objectif
apprendre ou réapprendre les bases d'une
alimentation équilibrée et d'une
activité physique
la ville de trappes s'inscrit en effet
dans le plan national nutrition santé 2
on s'inscri dessus parce que le haut
niveau de l'obésité pédiatrique la ville
de trappes est au-dessus de la moyenne
nationale donc le le taux à peu près des
deux des enfants on surcharge pondérale
on va dire sur le sur la ville est de
l'ordre de 18% alors qu'au niveau
national il tourne à 14 à 15%
si la ville enregistre une légère baisse
de l'obésité ces dernières années elle
poursuit son action pour être au moins
dans la moyenne nationale
ce jour là seulement 3 courageuses ont
accepté de relever le défi
durant 45 minutes entre midi et deux
places au cours de renforcement
musculaire dans les locaux de la mairie
objectif inciter le personnel municipal
à pratiquer une activité physique
régulière
voilà le fitness et ça c'est complet on
peut on peut travailler tout le corps
s'est rapidement et sans trop de
matériel donc c'est assez rapide sur le
temps du midi à faire ballon fait plus
dur l'inspirent 1 2 mais bien le jeu
mais en l'air encore étant donné que
c'est la semaine manger bouger
j'ai profité de cette occasion justement
pour me bouger je vais quand même tous
les midis faire un petit peu de marche
et là une opportunité était là et
donc je suis venu pour me bouger un
petit peu et j'en ai besoin je trouve
que c'est important avant l'été mais
pour après pouvoir le refaire chez moi
ça permet de connecter exercice pour
après pour continuer la semaine à manger
bouger une action intergénérationnelle
qui s'adresse donc aussi bien aux
enfants qu'aux adultes
ici au foyer fourcassa les seniors ou
encore si leurs ateliers
on a la preuve des failles et le produit
laitier la france ça c'est la base du
petit déjeuner idéal une nutritionniste
est venu échanger avec eux sur
l'équilibré alimentaire
parmi les sujets évoqués la prévention
de l'ostéoporose l'importance de se
faire plaisir mais pas seulement on a
parlé sur la famille des viandes
poissons off qui sont vraiment important
pour préserver la fonte musculaire et
donc prévenir la dénutrition qui est
quand même très fréquente chez les
personnes âgées ce qui est à peu près 3
à 4% des personnes âgées à domicile qui
sont dénutri et les chiffres sont bien
plus importants de ce conte à 50% en
institution l'objectif était aussi de
casser les idées reçues
vieillir par exemple n'implique pas
nécessairement de manger moins or c'est
faux seins les besoins restent les mêmes
peurs voire même supérieure pour
certaines familles d'aliments
ça permet de remettre quelque chose
qu'on oublie facilement et qu'on la
tendance à vouloir oublier tout ça au
total sur la semaine mangerbouger
environ 600 enfants et 300 adultes ont
pris part aux différents ateliers
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition l'institut l'institut
de promotion de la santé à saint quentin
en yvelines qui organise demain jeudi 22
mai une journée de dépistage des cancers
cutanés entre 9h et 12h et 14h et 17h de
dermatologues vous recevront
gratuitement dans leurs locaux à trappes
lippé est situé le long de la nationale
10 à hauteur de la mairie on quitte le
domaine de la santé pour celui de
l'environnement le biomimétisme cela ne
vous dit peut être rien pourtant la
ville de vélizy villacoublay si converti
tout doucement pour résumer cela a
simplement le biomimétisme c'est imiter
le rythme de la nature une exposition se
déroule actuellement jérémy et brasse
olivier maniscalco jonathan vilma ne s'y
sont rendus
et si la plus belle source d'inspiration
était la nature c'est la question qui
est posée à vélizy jusqu'au 23 mai à
londres une exposition sur le
biomimétisme permet d'aborder cette
problématique
mais qu'est ce que le biomimétisme d'où
vient cette notion le biomimétisme ça a
été théorisée par une scientifique
américaine en 1997 et ses théories en
fait cette démarche qui et comment on
peut s'inspirer du vivant pour produire
des des services des biens ou en
l'occurrence comme on veut le faire à
vélizy une ville durable en france
la ville biomimétique est encore
balbutiante aucune commune ne peut
d'ailleurs revendiqué ce qualificatif
mais comment peut se traduire
concrètement le biomimétisme à l'échelle
de la ville vous avez des réalisations
concrètes
par exemple comme les bio façade donc
l'intégration de cultures de microalgues
qu'on intègre aux façades de bâtiments
cultures de microalgues d'un côté
bâtiment de l'autre ont tout intérêt à
s'associer puisque l'un consomment du
co2 produit de l'oxygène les microarn
dans la photosynthèse le bâtiment nous
mêmes on produit beaucoup de co2 on sait
pas quoi en faire et on a besoin
d'oxygène
et puis on est à peu près dans les mêmes
ambiances thermique et donc ça a mené
effectivement à l'invention de ces
saisies aux façades la première bio
façade devrait voir le jour à nantes en
2015 un projet que le gouvernement
soutient financièrement et à vélizy des
étudiants de tecomah réfléchisse à
reconnecter le quartier louvois à la
forêt avoisinante
l'homme qui s'inspire de la nature le
concept peut paraître 9 pourtant il n'a
rien de récent à léonard de vinci qui a
conçu des machines enfants en tout cas
des plans en s'inspirant en s'inspirant
des animaux adler en 1900 au début du
20e siècle qui a qui a conçu son
un de ces avions espions de la
chauve-souris être en symbiose avec son
environnement
voilà donc la finalité du biomimétisme
un système idéal dont on est encore loin
mais que le cinéma a déjà imaginé dans
son film avatar james cameron avait déjà
mise en image selon auto suffisant mais
son histoire se dérouler dans une forêt
loin des pollutions urbaines l'europe et
vous notre dossier à découvrir depuis
maintenant deux semaines et a retrouvé à
chacun des épisodes sur notre site
internet aujourd'hui le centre
d'information europe direct nous parle
de l'importance de l'union dans le
secteur automobile un secteur
particulièrement important dans le
département des yvelines premier
département automobile de france de par
le nombre d'entreprises implantées le
nombre d'emplois que cela représente
tout cela c'est au micro de catherine
viola tôt alors l'europe a tout d'abord
imposé ce qu'on appelle une
immatriculation commune alors tout
simplement ça ça vise à lutter contre
la criminal la criminalité sur la route
qui utilisent des voitures notamment
pour tout ce qui est les trafics de
drogue et compagnie donc tout simplement
une une immatriculation commune un
fichier commun tout simplement pour
faciliter le travail des forces de
police pour
accélérer l'identification des voitures
notamment par exemple tout ce qui est
les criminels tous les chauffards en
fait qui roule à 150 à l'heure sur
l'autoroute alors qu'il ne devrait pas
donc ça c'est une première possibilité
l'union européenne a aussi standardiser
le permis de conduire alors on a
toujours l'habitude de notre petit
papier rose
mais maintenant l'union européenne s'est
surtout rendu compte d'une chose c'est
que ce papier qu'on le met dans la poche
et que le jeans face à la machine à
laver 20 c'est délicat le papier le
permis de conduire souffrez détruit et
on n'a pas de duplicata qui est
qui est délivrée donc l'union européenne
a tout simplement imposer un permis de
conduire comme un qui est donc son
format d'une carte de crédit qui sera
don qui est normalement en plastique et
en plastique est donc là aussi ça aide
tout simplement le travail des forces de
l'ordre pour tout ce qui est le contrôle
des véhicules
les premiers prémices sont en train
d'être délivrée est normalement
ainsi alors pas d'inquiétude pour ceux
qui encore le papier rose tout
simplement lorsqu'ils devront faire le
renouvellement du permis ils auront le
père les produire hors pair voilà
certains états se sont mis d'accord pour
le fait que les amendes puisse être
transférée donc notamment tout ce qui
est france allemagne angleterre espagne
portugal
on a aussi l'italie voilà il ya certains
états qui ont commencé à mettre en place
ces systèmes mais c'est de leur côté ce
n'est pas dans le cadre de l'union
européenne
prochain épisode de l'europe et vous ce
sera à demain dans le journal à 18h
comme chaque soir du sport solidaire
pour sa troisième édition le trophée
unicef de golf était un peu vendredi sur
le parcours du blue green de saint
quentin en yvelines un tournoi à
dimension caritative chaque joueur
devait verser 15 euros de droit
d'inscription entièrement reversés à
l'unicef
une sauf qu' une somme qui permettra de
financer un programme sur trois années
débuter en 2012 à madagascar pays de
près de 20 millions de personnes ou qui
demeure l'un des plus pauvres dans le
monde 76 % de la population vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté
tout ce qui tourne autour de l'éducation
c'est-à-dire la création d'écoles pour
permettre aux enfants d'y participer et
également sur les programmes de l'eau et
de l'assainissement de l'eau potable et
c'est ça le la difficulté est là bas et
puis dernier point aussi de lutter
contre certaines violences faites aux
enfants notamment dans le domaine du
tourisme sexuel qui sévit aussi à
madagascar
propos recueillis par anthony rennes
j'ajoute que la finale nationale est
prévue le 11 octobre prochain en
compagnie du champion de golf jean van
de velde
autre rendez vous sportif et solidaire
la course contre la faim 3 156 élèves de
6e de 5e du collège alexandre dumas à
maurepas à mobiliser après avoir trouver
des parrains et qui vendre leurs
kilomètres de course ils se sont élancés
pour parcourir parfois jusqu'à 10 km en
moyenne chaque année l'opération apporte
6000 euros à l'association action contre
la faim du cinéma aujourd'hui dans les
salles le blockbuster américain x men et
au casting
omar sy le trappistes lance sa carrière
américaine son interview et les
premières réactions des spectateurs le
fauteuil de professeurs et c'est
beaucoup plus facile à pousser que que
le que le fauteuil de france accusé
parce que pour le coup il pousse tout
seul alors
dans touchable à x men omar sy a
traversé l'atlantique et se découvre de
nouveaux talents de la comédie au film
d'action avec pour ce premier essai
hollywoodien à ses côtés hugh jackman ou
encore jennifer lawrence
omar sy lui campe bishop un personnage
apparu pour la première fois dans les
comics originaux en 1991 on est dans un
réseau apocalyptique où les mutants sont
pourchassés par une sorte de robot qu'on
appelle les sentinelles qui arrive à les
détecter et ils sont programmés pour le
tuer j'arrose franchement il se
débrouille on y croit au début j'avais
un peu peur quand j'arrive dans la salle
et il a présumément de réplique non plus
mais il sonne vraiment pas de souci non
leur connaît pas il est franchement est
tous différents c'est un grand acteur à
l'avenir prometteur
on remarque n'oubliez pas de revenir en
france pour n'en faire quand même
quelques films à soi
parce que
c'est un très très gros budget c'est un
très gros film c'est les moyens
colossaux une technique incroyable on
avait un moniteur pour chaque acteur on
avait les caméras 3d avec des grues dans
tous les sens n'avait eu tout un studio
juste pour nous les costumes les
accessoires les effets spéciaux tout
était sur place pour que le réalisateur
puisse avoir accès à tous dans le même
temps donc c'était juste énorme
omar sy que l'on verra aussi
prochainement à la fiche de good people
avec james franco ou encore de jurassic
world dont le tournage est en cours
côté français il retrouvera olivier
nakache et eric toledano avec samba une
histoire de jeunes sénégalais sans
papiers du cinéma social
de quoi lui assurer sa place de
personnalités préférées des français
encore longtemps
quel bilan continue à bosser sur mon
anglais peut-être que c'est ça le bilan
et pour terminer ce journal nous partons
une nouvelle fois pour cannes en
partenariat avec radio sensations
nicolas à kirillovitch franck david ont
rencontré aujourd'hui qu'entendu puis il
est originaire de plaisir il présente un
nouveau court métrage au short film
corner un espace dédié aux courts
métrages
à 23 ans il présente intact un film pour
lequel il se glisse également dans la
peau d'un comédien est l'histoire de
survivants qui découvre une maison
épargné par le temps sur une terre
ravagée par les zombies être présent à
cannes c'est pour lui profité d'une
vitrine médiatique prendre des contacts
pour réaliser son rêve faire enfin un
long métrage du court métrage s'appelle
intacte ça dure une dizaine de minutes
c'est de survivants dans un monde
apocalyptique de zombies ils ont bien
entendu la planète et c'est sur yon la
découvre une à une maison abandonnée
comme tant d'autres qu'ils ont vu sauf
que celle là est quasiment intact et
risque de bien de changer leur vie à
tout jamais mais bien et sinon
sortir vivant ça tu es par m
ce
lâchement habitants
l'avantagé client au short film corner
c'est déjà c'est le festival de cannes
qui est un des plus gros festivals au
monde est l'un des plus gros marchés du
film
donc ça permet de référencer à cannes ça
permet de tuer les accréditations sa
part et donc de pouvoir être présent ici
et c'est vraiment une vitrine en fait
c'est une marque de qualité de dire que
voilà on était présent sur steam corner
et de pouvoir rencontrer des
investisseurs des distributeurs des
acheteurs fin vraiment toutes les
personnes qui font le cinéma
du côté business sont présentes ici et
ça permet de les rencontrer de pouvoir
pour se mettre en valeur et de pouvoir
faire la promotion de son de son travail
en fait tout simplement et d'essayer de
préparer on va dire le projet suivant la
marche suivante l'étape suivante le
présent comme et raja a été exclu dans
plusieurs festivals et j'ai gagné
j'en ai gagné 2,1 à cannes qui s'appelle
tous en short
d'ailleurs qui rediffusera mon film
samedi à l'hôtel eden et et j'en ai
gagné un autre à metz ce prix du jury à
metz au festival les petites l'ap qui
était un festival de film franco
allemand et c'est vrai que le fait
d'avoir été pris au short film corner
permettait aussi quand je postulais des
courts métrages de dire voilà c'est pas
un film que j'ai fait dans mon garage en
cinq minutes que c'était un travail
sérieux et ça permet d'aider à pouvoir
être nominé quelque part prochain
journal en direct jeudi 18h soyez
prudents ce soir un bulletin d un
bulletin de vigilance orange a été émis
par la préfecture des yvelines en raison
de violents orages et qui pourraient se
poursuivre jusqu'à 23h pluies intenses
grêle rafales de vent à demain